[Music]
the ongoing fighting in Yemen has taken
a turn for the worse and a long civil
war in this small but strategic Arab
country could have a huge global impact
just who are the groups fighting for
control of Yemen and why Yemen is
perched on the edge of the Arabian
Peninsula and forms the babamon Deb a
narrow waterway through which most of
the world's oil passes who controls
Yemen could control the movement of oil
around the globe fighting in Yemen is
mainly between forces loyal to Sunni
president of drebber Mansour Hadi and a
group of rebels from the north known as
Houthis the Houthis are a minority Shia
religious group they formed an alliance
with the former President Ali Abdullah
Saleh now control most of the military
Houthis captured the capital Sanaa in
September and fourth president Hadi to
flee Houthi kept moving south and are
now closing in on Aden what's happening
in Yemen is widely seen as a proxy war
between Yemen's neighbors rival
countries Iran and Saudi Arabia the Shia
ruled Iran is reportedly backing the
Houthi and the Sunni ruled Saudi Arabia
had been propping up president Hadi
Saudi Arabia which shares a long border
with Yemen has been increasingly
concerned about a growing Iranian
influence in the country but further
complicating all this is another
entirely separate militant group
operating in Yemen Sunni Muslim
extremists who pledged allegiance to
al-qaeda they're fighting their own war
against both the government and the
Houthi rebels and have taken control of
large parts of the country it's a
complicated fight the rest of the world
and the oil markets are watching closely
[Music]